my name is Fred Castleberry I designed  menswear and tailored clothing I was  doing art my entire childhood going off  into college a next natural adult  grown-up decision was won't let's go and  make a living doing finance and business  after five years in that I was born out  of my mind  and started dabbling in more fashion  photography and then it was fashion  design and with everything that I  designed I definitely want it to feel  classic and timeless and so I'm trying  to do that through imagery through  copywriting and bland voice and through  films that we are making for Instagram  and that live on the blog and it's a way  that we style things we're trying to say  that it's been about experiences that  implements us I want guys and my clients  to feel that whenever they come into  contact with what Fe Castleberry is  weren't leaking without looking we're  doing without asking behaving slightly  in a mischievous way while doing so  dressed impeccably  you